Caption: foreign
Caption: okay
Caption: well thank you everyone for coming back
Caption: to jacquel Negal again up next we have
Caption: Aaron who's going to be talking about
Caption: unleashing the power of Visual Studio
Caption: code probably one of the more industry
Caption: changing editors of recent times I would
Caption: say so please everyone put your hands
Caption: together to welcome Aaron to the stage
Caption: thanks for having me
Caption: um as mentioned my name is Aaron I work
Caption: for Microsoft as part of the cloud
Caption: advocacy team I've been doing software
Caption: development and web development for
Caption: longer that I'm going to admit to or
Caption: that in a session that's being recorded
Caption: and streamed out but I I I've used a lot
Caption: of editors in my time like I I got
Caption: started with like pico and
Caption: um and stuff like that emacs on on Linux
Caption: machines when I was uh
Caption: first at Uni and then obviously have
Caption: graduated to more complex editors but
Caption: yeah like vs code is it's been huge like
Caption: in like the way that has changed how
Caption: people think about you know Simple Text
Caption: editors because at the end of the day
Caption: that's that's what it is and the fact
Caption: that I'm I'm here and you're stuck in a
Caption: room with me for the next 45 minutes to
Caption: hear me talk about a text editor I think
Caption: that's kind of a kind of a big deal out
Caption: but yeah if you if you want to uh get in
Caption: contact with you after the session ask
Caption: me any questions that I don't get a
Caption: chance to cover off during uh during the
Caption: talk uh that's my social media and uh
Caption: website and email address and all that
Caption: kind of stuff
Caption: but um before we jump into the talk I
Caption: want to thank the sponsors
Caption: um I've been doing DDD conferences in
Caption: Australia for 12 years now and they
Caption: can't happen without sponsors um like
Caption: all the ones we've got here particularly
Caption: Microsoft they're an awesome sponsor you
Caption: should really come and see us at the
Caption: booth afterwards um yeah and that's
Caption: where I'll be hanging out for the rest
Caption: of the day so if you do want to come ask
Caption: any other questions find me there
Caption: but
Caption: we're here to to talk about the power of
Caption: vs code
Caption: um no so whether whether you're brand
Caption: new to the tech industry you're looking
Caption: to get into Tech
Caption: um or you've been in it for you know the
Caption: nearly 20 years that I've been in it
Caption: um yeah I hope that there's going to be
Caption: something in this session for you
Caption: um I I've put this together because I
Caption: I'm I think that it's while it seems so
Caption: simple it's a text editor there's so
Caption: many hidden things in it
Caption: um but to get started I'm going to just
Caption: make sure that you know for those of you
Caption: that haven't used vs code before or you
Caption: haven't had
Caption: um I had much experience with it let's
Caption: just make sure that we're all on the
Caption: same page so we're gonna do a quick lap
Caption: around vs code so this is uh vs code um
Caption: I've got a project of mine open there um
Caption: don't try and read the text it's not
Caption: particularly interesting or relevant um
Caption: but what I'm going to do is I want to
Caption: break down the core features of the text
Caption: editor
Caption: across the top we have the the title bar
Caption: and that's where you your menu systems
Caption: are and like every application Under the
Caption: Sun has got a title bar of someone's
Caption: description but the interesting thing
Caption: about the vs code one is that it's
Caption: highly customizable in fact like
Caption: everything in vs code is highly
Caption: customizable so at the top it's got
Caption: things like the the file name um of the
Caption: file that we're currently got open it's
Caption: got the the information about the uh the
Caption: repo this is connected to I'm connected
Caption: to a remote vs code instance so I'm
Caption: using it with WSL so it's got that
Caption: information in there but you can
Caption: actually edit that and change you know
Caption: strip out information you don't think is
Caption: going to be needed or you don't want to
Caption: display in there and this can be really
Caption: really useful some someone that has
Caption: maybe some attention uh issues and some
Caption: some newer diversion in that regardless
Caption: I can strip out the stuff that isn't
Caption: like I don't need to have it there I
Caption: don't need it to tell me I'm in vs code
Caption: because I know I'm in vs code um for
Caption: example like you can you can modify it
Caption: to be the editor that you need it to be
Caption: we have the sidebar um on the left-hand
Caption: side um I actually hit mine on the right
Caption: hand side and you know I'll I'll show
Caption: you uh why when I jump into actually
Caption: editor but this is where we have like
Caption: our files and our folder structure
Caption: that's all there it's where we get to
Caption: the debugger we get to Source control so
Caption: we can um like make our commits into the
Caption: git repo or
Caption: um is there any other source control
Caption: that people still use like it's like SVN
Caption: oh now now am I really dating myself CVS
Caption: anyone anyone serious yeah yeah
Caption: um but so the other thing with the
Caption: sidebar is that uh extensions that you
Caption: can add to vs code can also introduce
Caption: things in here so I've got a couple
Caption: additional icons down the bottom there
Caption: the Azure extension a Docker extension
Caption: and a few things like that so that that
Caption: um there's functionality specific to
Caption: that I don't know a complex extension
Caption: like the Azure one that allows you work
Caption: with Azure resources you know it's all
Caption: there and I can do it with inside of the
Caption: editor so the editor goes beyond just
Caption: being a um a text editing place it's
Caption: also a more complex tool there are seats
Caption: up the front feel like you don't feel
Caption: like you need to awkwardly stand around
Caption: the back
Caption: down the bottom we have our status bar
Caption: and this is again showing just a whole
Caption: bunch of uh like little quick quick
Caption: pieces of information things like what
Caption: branch are we on in the the git repo
Caption: that we've got open now are there any
Caption: errors or warnings in the project that
Caption: I've got open
Caption: um what's the what's the lining Coatings
Caption: because that's a painful thing there are
Caption: still seats please do come in don't you
Caption: don't feel like you need to stand in the
Caption: doorway
Caption: um and like what what uh language
Caption: Services being used so this is It's a
Caption: HTML file that's got open HTML but I can
Caption: change that to you know what and that
Caption: indicates then and that can be useful if
Caption: uh you know you've uh working with you
Caption: know multiple languages that uh maybe uh
Caption: more esoteric than uh and kind of just
Caption: you common run in the middle sort of
Caption: stuff but again you can turn as much of
Caption: this stuff off as you want because again
Caption: you might not want that information you
Caption: might not need it there because you know
Caption: it's contextually irrelevant to you or
Caption: um you find it distracting to have that
Caption: kind of stuff all there
Caption: uh then we've got our terminal across
Caption: the bottom so there's an integrated
Caption: terminal in vs code
Caption: um uh that we can we can open up but we
Caption: can open up as many terminal Windows as
Caption: we can um when I'm working I tend to
Caption: have just vs code open and I don't even
Caption: have a separate terminal app running
Caption: anymore I just pop the terminal up um
Caption: run my npm commands or run my git
Caption: installs oh sorry get my GIF commands
Caption: and stuff like that
Caption: um all within here also interestingly um
Caption: if you do run like a node uh command so
Caption: like in a npm start to how to run a web
Caption: server from the VSCO terminal it will
Caption: automatically attach a debugger for you
Caption: you don't even have to like do anything
Caption: extra to get debugging running for like
Caption: a node application yeah npm start as
Caption: your debugger already ready to go
Caption: um and then there's actually a text
Caption: editing surface as well like it's been
Caption: like five minutes and I haven't talked
Caption: about the fact that you could edit a
Caption: text document in a text editor
Caption: but I mean you can it's it's it's
Caption: obviously the core feature um no it does
Caption: all the things you'd expect from a text
Caption: that ever does syntax highlighting um I
Caption: have like errors and stuff like that
Caption: will appear if the language service that
Caption: you're using is um is servicing that
Caption: information up
Caption: um and this is a HTML file it's you know
Caption: if it's got a variety of colors in there
Caption: to indicate the different things inside
Caption: of that
Caption: and lastly we have our mini map view of
Caption: the file so there's like a 10 000 view
Caption: of the file that you're in
Caption: um and this is not a particularly long
Caption: file so it's all condensed at the top
Caption: and you can see even like the the
Caption: colorization appears there um but this
Caption: can be useful if you're scrolling
Caption: through a thousand long thousands of
Caption: like a file that's like a thousand miles
Caption: long not that anyone's writing like
Caption: single files that are like like several
Caption: thousands Lines no no one does that do
Caption: they
Caption: I see some I see some awkward uh awkward
Caption: nodding of the head there
Caption: um all right so that's vs code in a very
Caption: quick nutshell uh and you know kind of
Caption: like all like all the different aspects
Caption: of vs code and the things that are in
Caption: there so let's now
Caption: talk about all right how can we use it
Caption: to be productive and and for me being
Caption: productive means keyboard like I'm I'm a
Caption: keyboard um user I I don't have an
Caption: external Mouse like when I'm when I'm
Caption: using my laptop I don't use an external
Caption: Mouse I can use an external Mouse at
Caption: home because I have a desktop but I so
Caption: I've done everything I can to try and
Caption: memorize as many keyboard shortcuts as I
Caption: can I know a scary amount of word
Caption: shortcuts
Caption: so like I can power using my way through
Caption: Microsoft Word
Caption: um but also in vs code
Caption: um and
Caption: let's jump over
Caption: there's enough slides at the moment
Caption: let's jump over and actually have a look
Caption: at BS code and some stuff that we've got
Caption: in here so I've got a couple of
Caption: different vs coded this is open
Caption: um
Caption: the the you should be able to read the
Caption: text but again don't worry about the
Caption: text in there this is mostly my notes so
Caption: feel free to read ahead and just then
Caption: zone out to me because this is what I'm
Caption: going to be covering but
Caption: if there is only one shortcut key in vs
Caption: code that you learn it is control p
Caption: this brings up
Caption: um the defaults to the file picker so I
Caption: can use this to find the readme file hit
Caption: enter and opens the file I'm currently
Caption: in but we can also use uh this to say
Caption: type a question mark and here are all
Caption: the other things that we can get from
Caption: this um the it moves on from being just
Caption: a file a file picker to being a command
Caption: palette so I could do a greater than
Caption: symbol and then these are all the things
Caption: like the actions I can perform within uh
Caption: vs code I can open the settings or I can
Caption: go to uh like uh so I've actually
Caption: traveled on a thing called screencast
Caption: mode uh so as I type the keyboard
Caption: shortcuts uh they'll pop up quickly on
Caption: the screen so you know I'm like here's
Caption: the keyboard shortcut and you're like I
Caption: can't see the keyboard Aaron you're up
Caption: there and there's a screen
Caption: um so I've got that turned on so you can
Caption: see uh so control P comes with the file
Caption: picker control shift p
Caption: if I hit the correct Keys um go straight
Caption: to the actions so uh this is just a
Caption: because it's a quick one because this is
Caption: probably the most common thing that you
Caption: tend to do from the file picker uh so
Caption: from from the the command palette
Caption: um other things I like like if I type
Caption: view I can get to the slide bar
Caption: um on the right hand side there cool
Caption: it's a false to the left-hand side I
Caption: move it to the right hand side because
Caption: if I expand it and collapse it
Caption: pops in and out if I have it on the left
Caption: let's see if I can remember how to move
Caption: it to the left
Caption: I actually can't remember how to move it
Caption: to the left it's somewhere in settings
Caption: it's been so long since I've done that
Caption: oh was it
Caption: ah excellent there we go
Caption: um control B hides and shows it but this
Caption: is really annoying for me because you
Caption: now your focal point is um is Shifting
Caption: because the the editor surface is moving
Caption: so that's why I move mine to the right
Caption: um anyway so control P View and then I
Caption: can go to explore pop up into this bit
Caption: or control B P view uh debug
Caption: and get to the debug section okay
Caption: um so I don't have to maybe like
Caption: memorize um the shortcut keys I think
Caption: that's wow
Caption: F5 I think might get you to that I
Caption: forget
Caption: um but I just do control P view
Caption: um but also then I can say in Explorer
Caption: if I was in Explorer I can then go to
Caption: like the uh the folders or the outline
Caption: view or um you know so I can actually
Caption: navigate the sub menus within or the sub
Caption: sections with inside of
Caption: um the the sidebar um using the command
Caption: palette again just all off the off the
Caption: keyboard there
Caption: another one um term for uh quick access
Caption: to anything to do with thermals and
Caption: create a new terminal
Caption: that one's going to be down there and a
Caption: term
Caption: whoops
Caption: turn and then I can create
Caption: another terminal
Caption: and then I can swap between them
Caption: um but we tell them they're all called
Caption: zsh because that's the shell that I'm
Caption: using in this case uh but it was like
Caption: well which one which ones which how do I
Caption: easily know that well Ctrl shift p
Caption: command palette and then we're going to
Caption: go terminal rename and we'll call this
Caption: one we'll call this git because I'm
Caption: going to use that for my git operations
Caption: and now if I go control P term I can
Caption: type git and jump to that particular
Caption: terminal so this is usually if you've
Caption: got a couple opens maybe you're maybe
Caption: you're building an application has got a
Caption: like a front end and a back end and if
Caption: you've got a couple of terminals open
Caption: ones running the back end um like the
Caption: npm command to run the back end the
Caption: others uh the the front end web
Caption: application so you've got multiple
Caption: terminals running node processors well
Caption: you could rename them so that you can
Caption: jump back and forth and you can see the
Caption: uh which one like the log messages from
Caption: the right one um easily from there
Caption: all right
Caption: um so
Caption: yeah Ctrl P probably like the number one
Caption: shortcut to take away and to remember uh
Caption: from this
Caption: now I'm talking about screencast mode
Caption: which I've got turned on and we can get
Caption: to that from settings control comma
Caption: we'll get to settings we type screen
Caption: cast
Caption: and I have that done here um you can
Caption: actually let me hide terminals uh
Caption: control backtick will collapse the
Caption: terminals um error at the bottom hide
Caption: and show short back tick and how's that
Caption: control B to collapse that um so with uh
Caption: with screencast mode Um this can be good
Caption: for pair programming as well uh so
Caption: you're uh whether you're doing it like
Caption: as a
Caption: um like a remote peer programming
Caption: session or you've just got someone um
Caption: that's sitting next to you and you know
Caption: you don't want them kind of breathing
Caption: down your neck trying to work out well
Caption: they see what you're doing
Caption: um and just total it on can be a useful
Caption: thing but you can it can be a little bit
Caption: annoying because like every key stroke
Caption: is getting captured in here but I can
Caption: change that and say that I only want it
Caption: to show you just like the commands so if
Caption: I'm using the command or I'll sort of
Caption: those kind of keys it'll just show those
Caption: up
Caption: um and that could be a bit more useful I
Caption: guess if you're doing demos and stuff
Caption: like that
Caption: um change font size change uh styling
Caption: all that kind of stuff there
Caption: um another useful uh mode of uh this
Caption: code is Zen mode control K Zed
Caption: now you just you you want to kind of
Caption: turn off as many of the distractions as
Caption: you've got because you you're like
Caption: you're you're in you're in the moment
Caption: like you're trying to you know get
Caption: through a bug or whatever the case may
Caption: be
Caption: um this as you can see it's hidden
Caption: pretty much everything we've hidden the
Caption: sidebar we've hit the status bar
Caption: um the the top menus um hidden like we
Caption: don't even have the you can't even see
Caption: the different files we've got open I
Caption: only have one file open at the moment
Caption: anyway but like you would you could
Caption: control tab to get between the the files
Caption: but yeah this is like you know it's a
Caption: it's a focus mode like we've hidden
Caption: everything that could be a potential
Caption: distraction just so we can focus on the
Caption: thing that we're currently trying to do
Caption: uh control KZ to get back out of that
Caption: there are a bunch of settings for Zen
Caption: mode as well so let's say that it's
Caption: actually maybe a little bit too
Caption: aggressive I do still want to have uh
Caption: line numbers in here I can say that well
Caption: no don't hide the line numbers
Caption: go back into zen mode
Caption: so I can still have my line numbers in
Caption: there because I like I remember I find
Caption: that useful so I can navigate up and
Caption: down or I know where uh where I'm at and
Caption: things like that
Caption: customize it for the way that you want
Caption: to use it it's not just the it's not
Caption: just trying to be an editor that is
Caption: generic and you like it forces you to
Caption: work in a particular way no you
Caption: customize it for the needs that you've
Caption: got
Caption: and I'm just going to turn that back on
Caption: so that my zen mode is nice
Caption: clean
Caption: um from uh from an accessibility
Caption: standpoint there's been a lot of work in
Caption: vs code to make that uh an easy Editor
Caption: to use
Caption: um and something that
Caption: I think that people don't consider um
Caption: too much and and what and I know I
Caption: didn't consider this for a long time but
Caption: I used to work uh with a colleague who
Caption: has albinism and he had very poor
Caption: eyesight as a result of that so he had
Caption: to have his font um incredibly large so
Caption: that he could read it and and that kind
Caption: of stuff but that can be a problem when
Caption: you're working on code files because we
Caption: tend to well
Caption: I'm lazy so I just you know write things
Caption: as long as I can I I've got a giant
Caption: screen at home and a reasonable enough
Caption: eyesight so I'm quite content to have
Caption: you know hundreds and hundreds of
Caption: characters spread across a 32 inch
Caption: monitor because that's like that's my
Caption: working experience but that might not be
Caption: great for everyone on the team so we can
Caption: turn on editor rules in uh
Caption: there's code whoops let me just control
Caption: control K control U to comment and
Caption: uncomment
Caption: um so control uh yeah control K is yeah
Caption: okay U is uncomment control K C is to
Caption: comment
Caption: um but there we are so I've turned on
Caption: some editor rules um and so you can see
Caption: these uh lines there or you can maybe
Caption: make it a bit like get that real retro
Caption: experience and just have a whole heap of
Caption: scan lines across the screen uh but you
Caption: can then customize the colors for them
Caption: and it could be usually it's like oh
Caption: well we want to keep to it like an 80
Caption: character width because we know that
Caption: there's someone on our team that that's
Caption: kind of the the width of code that they
Caption: can show at any point in time so we
Caption: don't just want to be mindful of that so
Caption: we you know we have an indicator in
Caption: there or you know you're you're working
Caption: on something that's got to be shipped to
Caption: a Mainframe and it is actually like an
Caption: 80 character width uh terminal that
Caption: they're going to be working with so so
Caption: you want to know where 80 characters is
Caption: or you're one of those people that is
Caption: militant about no it doesn't matter that
Caption: we can have a curved 49 inch monitor
Caption: around us I am going to have a fixed
Caption: width of 80 characters in my texts
Caption: because that's that's what I grew up
Caption: with uh coding um but yeah it's just
Caption: like it's it's kind of one of those
Caption: random little features that I think
Caption: um can be useful particularly when
Caption: you're considering
Caption: uh how other people are also going to be
Caption: working on
Caption: um a bio code base or something like
Caption: that for you but we'll turn them off
Caption: because they might be a little bit
Caption: distracted
Caption: uh another kind of actually I should
Caption: have kept that open Ctrl shift t
Caption: open the last file
Caption: another thing that uh
Caption: is um is useful and uh I tend to forget
Caption: to turn it on because I I add it for
Caption: like the demos I do then I take it out
Caption: because
Caption: um I don't try to clean up my uh my
Caption: workspace beforehand and then forget to
Caption: have it put it back in uh they're called
Caption: code actions on save so you want to
Caption: perform something when uh when the file
Caption: is being saved that's what code actions
Caption: on Save code action on Save
Caption: and oops
Caption: we can get it to do a variety of
Caption: different things so what
Caption: control space one of those is organize
Caption: Imports so we're going to hit set that
Caption: to true so let's say that we're working
Caption: on like a Javascript file one here and
Caption: we've got a like a a linting rule where
Caption: we have to we want to keep the order of
Caption: our Imports in an alphabetical manner
Caption: it's a it's a fairly common integral
Caption: well I've got them a bit uh back with
Caption: you because I want the destructor
Caption: Imports at the very top
Caption: so I can go control shift p and then uh
Caption: all organize Imports or shift alt o is
Caption: the the default shortcut key for that
Caption: one
Caption: I can hit it and it's going to do that
Caption: for me or with code actions on Save now
Caption: as soon as I hit Ctrl s to save the file
Caption: it's going to just run that for me yeah
Caption: it just like it's a useful little thing
Caption: particularly if like those are the sorts
Caption: of things that you're putting in your
Caption: like your linting rules
Caption: um there's also another one in there for
Caption: uh for fix all um so it'll uh if you've
Caption: got a like a linter installed that is
Caption: going to be applying um fixing rules it
Caption: can try and run those for you so like
Caption: you know eslint um it'll try and apply
Caption: those fixes to the file as you hit save
Caption: so okay just like little quality of life
Caption: improvements that are there
Caption: uh
Caption: come back
Caption: um
Caption: oh uh the last one from a setting
Caption: standpoint that could be useful is this
Caption: default editor language
Caption: um
Caption: what it will do is it will attempt to
Caption: work out from the workspace
Caption: what is the most common programming
Caption: language of the files that are in there
Caption: and when you do control n to create a
Caption: new file it will assign that language
Caption: service to the new file so you
Caption: immediately get your code completion
Caption: turned on for the file you immediately
Caption: get the correct like syntax highlighting
Caption: and colorizations and stuff like that
Caption: but you can actually overwrite that
Caption: setting uh so you know I want new files
Caption: in this repo to be always defaulted to
Caption: markdown for example I do that for my my
Caption: blog is running in markdown so I default
Caption: the files to always be marked down
Caption: unless I change the the the file with
Caption: Ctrl k m
Caption: it's okay m not control K control M Ctrl
Caption: k m and that's how we can change the
Caption: language of the file
Caption: um and so yeah but you can you can set
Caption: you can let vs code attempt to figure
Caption: out what should be the default language
Caption: for a new file or you can force that uh
Caption: with settings
Caption: um active active editor language is the
Caption: the default that's there
Caption: all right
Caption: we'll come back to slides for a minute
Caption: because I want to talk about extensions
Caption: vs code has a huge amount of
Caption: extensibility
Caption: and out of that has grown a massive
Caption: extensions ecosystem everyone's going to
Caption: have their favorite extension that you
Caption: should have installed or that they
Caption: believe is that it's going to change the
Caption: way that you use vs code and there are
Caption: literally thousands of extensions so I
Caption: am not going to cover them all off in
Caption: here I'm just going to talk about a
Caption: couple that I think are really useful
Caption: and that I've got installed on my
Caption: machine and they're generic ones they're
Caption: not
Caption: um they're not specific to a particular
Caption: programming language or anything like
Caption: that so these are these are six um top
Caption: ones for me um editor config for vs code
Caption: so editor config if you're unfamiliar
Caption: with it is a file that you can put into
Caption: a repo that that you use to define the
Caption: set default things about a file like
Caption: what is the default line encoding how
Caption: many are we using tabs or spaces now
Caption: what's in default indentation depth and
Caption: you can then set that for
Caption: um uh like different for different files
Caption: so maybe you're like your your bash
Caption: files they need to have an LF as the
Caption: default line encoding whereas other
Caption: files you might want to have a crlf as
Caption: the the line encoding and then you can
Caption: and so that that one's a useful one just
Caption: to enforce standardization with inside
Caption: of a code base
Caption: I'll get on pull requests and issues uh
Caption: just manage all your GitHub stuff uh
Caption: what full requested issues aspects of
Caption: GitHub from within vs code don't have to
Caption: jump out to the website don't have to
Caption: jump out to the the GitHub
Caption: um uh desktop application or anything
Caption: like that um just do it from vs code
Caption: um rest client if you're doing anything
Caption: that involves calling apis rest client
Caption: is so useful
Caption: um it's the same as like Postman and
Caption: Insomniac and all those sorts of tools
Caption: so it allows you to invoke HTTP
Caption: um requests but the advantage of rest
Caption: client is that you create a file and
Caption: then you just execute the things out of
Caption: that file so you can have you know your
Caption: examples of how to call an API as a file
Caption: that you just check in part of your git
Caption: repo
Caption: and then you like it's it's all there
Caption: it's all in one location and you can
Caption: then execute those from uh with the side
Caption: of vs code
Caption: uh peacock this was actually written by
Caption: a colleague of mine at Microsoft uh and
Caption: it's it's what a what it does is it
Caption: changes the colors of like the borders
Caption: of vs code so you would have seen uh the
Caption: one that I had uh
Caption: where is it
Caption: it's my lovely background
Caption: uh so see how this has got the green
Caption: around it uh peacock's done that so if
Caption: you've got a couple of vs code instances
Caption: open maybe you want to um you set
Caption: different colors on them so you know
Caption: which one it is as your old tabbing
Caption: um between your uh between your windows
Caption: uh code spell checker funny story was uh
Caption: when I was working for a company a
Caption: number of years ago we were um we were
Caption: building a custom CRM and we needed to
Caption: keep track of our person name history
Caption: because you know if someone changed
Caption: their name we need to attract that so we
Caption: created a table called person name
Caption: history
Caption: also we thought that's what we named the
Caption: table
Caption: it wasn't until several months later
Caption: that we realized that we'd actually
Caption: named the table person named his Troy
Caption: we'd also read in customer RM it had
Caption: generated a whole bunch of C sharp code
Caption: from the database so we had all these
Caption: classes called person name history
Caption: uh you would get that person if you have
Caption: a collection of person named his Troy's
Caption: uh and all that kind of stuff
Caption: um it was then like this was then in in
Caption: testing and it was just it was too hard
Caption: to go back and fix it so like oh well
Caption: we're shipping to production with person
Caption: name his choice
Caption: you want an extension like this one like
Caption: code spell check
Caption: sure you don't do that
Caption: um I I and I'm just horrendously bad at
Caption: spelling you know the best of times so I
Caption: use that on my blog and it's just like
Caption: it's just so nice and uh that I could
Caption: just not have to worry about that
Caption: uh and then the last one is to do
Caption: highlight so uh to do how I'd actually
Caption: like to use with uh the GitHub uh one so
Caption: where where you put likewife or like put
Caption: a comment in you know to do I'm totally
Caption: going to fix this code later
Caption: like and you totally gonna come back and
Caption: do that right
Caption: um what what to do highlight will do is
Caption: it will actually find all those in and
Caption: give you a list of that like you can see
Caption: that with inside of vs code like here's
Caption: all the to-do's you've got with inside
Caption: of the solution
Caption: um but then I combine that with the
Caption: GitHub full requests and issues so that
Caption: you you just select that to do and then
Caption: immediately create a GitHub issue out of
Caption: that so that it's not just in the code
Caption: base that you're totally going to fix it
Caption: later it's also in your GitHub issues
Caption: that you're totally going to come back
Caption: and fix
Caption: and you just gets de-prioritized down
Caption: the back
Caption: um yeah uh these things are like yeah
Caption: the ones that I find really useful and
Caption: like I said these aren't specific to any
Caption: kind of program you're like whether
Caption: you're writing markdown or python or net
Caption: or whatever um these can all help out
Caption: there
Caption: but I'm a web developer at heart uh so I
Caption: want to talk about a couple of
Caption: um my favorite uh web developer or
Caption: JavaScript developer extensions
Caption: um and uh since my animations are not
Caption: quite right uh so
Caption: um prettier so uh if you're if you're
Caption: doing JavaScript projects prettier is
Caption: kind of like it's the de facto standard
Caption: I think at the moment for doing
Caption: um code formatting uh for JavaScript
Caption: applications it also does like HTML and
Caption: CSS and I think a couple other languages
Caption: markdown stuff like that there is an
Caption: extension for vs code so that uh like
Caption: you don't have to do anything it just uh
Caption: it includes it and then it gets you can
Caption: set that as the default format of
Caption: formatter for for the right files are
Caption: you JavaScript files so when you um in
Caption: vs code you tell it to format the file
Caption: it will execute prettier for you uh
Caption: combine that with eslint so then you can
Caption: get your linting
Caption: um rules uh the the linting information
Caption: surfaced up with inside of the editor so
Caption: you can quickly jump around and find
Caption: those without having to wait until the
Caption: CIA build has failed because you didn't
Caption: run uh npm no you didn't run your yield
Caption: into before pushing uh npm
Caption: um this is a just a useful extension uh
Caption: for working with npm I will like when
Caption: you're working in a package Json file uh
Caption: you can do control space uh on the
Caption: version and we'll show you the the
Caption: vision
Caption: um versions available for that package
Caption: and also give you like the the December
Caption: um
Caption: City attack sports are like do you want
Caption: the the hat or do you want a
Caption: star or whatever the case may be um so
Caption: yeah you can uh make sure your lucky
Caption: patch is the right point and the last
Caption: one is
Caption: um we shift uh for vs code a bunch of
Caption: extent an extension for uh Edge so that
Caption: you can do
Caption: um like work with the browser from vs
Caption: code and I'm going to have a crack at
Caption: actually testing that one out now
Caption: because I totally didn't just try and do
Caption: this before okay before I came to uh
Caption: into the room for the session I totally
Caption: this was all pre-planned and done this
Caption: is the day-to-day Perth website
Caption: I brought it down um I'm gonna let's do
Caption: npm start
Caption: and we'll see if that works there we go
Caption: um and I do have the edge extension
Caption: installed uh so the edge extension I
Caption: think it also works with chrome to a
Caption: degree so because it's it's chromium
Caption: browsers but this is
Caption: not working fantastic all right
Caption: um well the
Caption: oh I had to do like npm building npm run
Caption: build
Caption: I totally didn't read that readme either
Caption: so I was just like I can clone this run
Caption: npm install and yeah like everything
Caption: will be fine yep yep that might not be
Caption: fine that's going to take a while um
Caption: let's try I'll show I'll show us a
Caption: slightly different uh
Caption: one of it that does work but not quite
Caption: as much as I wanted there uh so oh
Caption: another one from there task and then
Caption: these are uh scripts that I've already
Caption: got inside of my repo uh that I can run
Caption: uh this is my this is my blog I'm just
Caption: going to uh run the the little web
Caption: server for that
Caption: it's open and now I'm going to use the
Caption: edge extension which I've got installed
Caption: here
Caption: and there it is I have my website there
Caption: and I want to hit open
Caption: so there we go I I do apologize it is
Caption: going to be very cramped because it's
Caption: all zoomed in for the editor but there's
Caption: my there's my website on one side and
Caption: there's a Dom inspector on the other
Caption: side so I could go hey let's find
Caption: that element
Caption: so I can like I can ins like all that
Caption: Dom inspectory goodness that's there I
Caption: have the the CSS um information there uh
Caption: you probably can't read that unless
Caption: you're in the front view rows but uh I'm
Caption: actually using SAS to uh instead of like
Caption: raw CSS so I'm compiling that down to
Caption: CSS and that's telling me this is uh
Caption: banner.scss file
Caption: um and
Caption: if I wasn't
Caption: using it in the way that I'm using it I
Caption: could actually click through that file
Caption: and we'll go through the file and disk
Caption: unfortunately it's not working in this
Caption: particular vs code instance because I'm
Caption: connected to a remote machine and it
Caption: doesn't like so it can't access the file
Caption: system uh properly to do that pass
Caption: through that's why I was trying to get
Caption: this one up and running and it's a good
Caption: idea that I didn't wait for that because
Caption: it's still building
Caption: um but if if you're working with it just
Caption: like directly on your Mac or Windows
Caption: machine or Linux machine then um like it
Caption: like you can click through to that file
Caption: if you edit in the Styles editor with
Caption: inside of this extension here it will
Caption: actually push those to the file on disk
Caption: so like you know just like full
Caption: real-time feedback loop that you get
Caption: there yeah it's a it's a really Nifty
Caption: extension and I'm not just trying to
Caption: pimp it because I work for Microsoft and
Caption: I think Edge is actually a decent
Caption: browser
Caption: um like being able to like have like
Caption: having everything contextually in the
Caption: one location I find is quite useful
Caption: all right
Caption: now
Caption: I did Consulting work for nearly a
Caption: decade before joining Microsoft and
Caption: something that was always frustrating
Caption: when uh I was doing my Consulting work
Caption: was that I would come to a new client
Caption: and be like cool ma'am welcome
Caption: um here's your machine
Caption: boom big pile of paper uh that's the
Caption: setup guide for your machine we'll see
Caption: at the end of the week who's who's
Caption: experienced something like that I'm
Caption: saying I've seen a lot of heads tonight
Caption: yeah it and just like
Caption: I feel bad because like I know how much
Caption: I'm billing for you to be here and
Caption: you're telling me it's going to take me
Caption: a week before I can be productive
Caption: because I've got to you know like and
Caption: you go through it and then it doesn't
Caption: work anyway oh yeah sorry it turns out
Caption: that um no we're actually using the the
Caption: newer version of Reddit sorry just not
Caption: like not the old version that's listed
Caption: in there can you actually got to
Caption: download the new can you can you upgrade
Caption: that or
Caption: um oh yeah we've we forgot to add this
Caption: step or actually can you go talk to uh
Caption: this person on the other side of the
Caption: room because they're going to have to
Caption: help you um because yeah we haven't
Caption: documented some of the new stuff that
Caption: they've added to the uh the environment
Caption: and like ah it's just it's so
Caption: frustrating
Caption: um but with vs code
Caption: um one of the one of the things we can
Caption: do with that is uh I mentioned before
Caption: like editor config and things like that
Caption: just to reinforce them like code
Caption: standardization but you can even do that
Caption: to the point of like editor
Caption: standardization
Caption: where
Caption: um where we can have inside of our DOT
Caption: vs code folder uh we can include things
Caption: like
Caption: settings so settings that are specific
Caption: for this repo so when you open this repo
Caption: in vs code these settings are going to
Caption: be applied so like if if you've got like
Caption: a you know default file extension that
Caption: you want to set you can set that just
Caption: for this project so that you opened up
Caption: you're not having to set this on a
Caption: machine wide wide config
Caption: um another one I don't have it in this
Caption: one but I think I might have it in
Caption: actually I'll have it in here maybe
Caption: I have so many oh there's so many things
Caption: open uh whoops let's collapse that
Caption: now
Caption: uh you can also include uh I don't have
Caption: extensions in this one either ah but I
Caption: know where it was I did see one earlier
Caption: inside of this vs code folder
Caption: extensions so these are recommended
Caption: extensions that you should have to work
Caption: on this particular project so they're um
Caption: they're encourage you to install the
Caption: Chrome debugger which ironically is
Caption: actually deprecated
Caption: they're recommending that you install
Caption: editor config and prettier and and uh
Caption: ESPN so what will happen is when you
Caption: open up this uh this folder in vs code
Caption: if you don't have those extensions
Caption: installed you'll get a note noticing
Caption: there are recommended extensions would
Caption: you like to install them so that way you
Caption: can make sure that everyone's kind of
Caption: got that same sort of development
Caption: experience
Caption: but
Caption: let's go back into the slides
Caption: in a moment there we go
Caption: but there's another level we can take
Caption: this to and that's with a feature of vs
Caption: code uh called uh Dev containers
Caption: so
Caption: a Dev container is a way to dockerize
Caption: the development environment that you're
Caption: working in or dockerize the the
Caption: yeah the thing that you're you're
Caption: building with and
Caption: then because it's in a environment's in
Caption: a docking container you can control
Caption: what's there so you can pre-install like
Caption: the correct version of node or net or go
Caption: or whatever runtime you're working with
Caption: you can pre-install like a database
Caption: um and
Caption: I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep just dropping
Caption: in and out of my slides
Caption: uh so
Caption: this project Yep this one here so this
Caption: is one of my open source projects it's a
Caption: F-sharp project if anyone wants to talk
Caption: F sharp come see me I'm like probably
Caption: the only person here that actually cares
Caption: about that but it's awesome and if
Caption: you're a DOT net developer learn F-sharp
Caption: um but this is a project for working
Caption: with uh Cosmos DB uh from F-sharp but
Caption: for local development well I don't have
Caption: to speed up an Azure resource for for
Caption: Cosmos Divi or if someone wants to come
Caption: along and contribute a fix to it or a
Caption: feature or anything like that I don't
Caption: want them to have to stand up at Azure
Caption: account stand up for a cosmos instance
Caption: inside of there so I have a Dev
Caption: container that does that for you
Caption: um this one is using uh Docker compose
Caption: so it has the environment that you're
Caption: going to be actually developing with
Caption: inside of so this will pre-install
Caption: the.net runtime for you the correct
Caption: version because I'm working on dot net
Caption: six so that'll all be pre-installed for
Caption: you plus a few tools make uh for working
Caption: with F sharp but then I have a another
Caption: Docker container that started up next to
Caption: it which is going to be the cosmos DB
Caption: emulator I then also so when I open in
Caption: vs code it detects this Dev Contender
Caption: says hey do you want to run this as a
Caption: Dev container you do that it will start
Caption: this all up
Caption: um it will start up the the docking
Caption: container side by side and now I I can
Caption: do full local development and I haven't
Caption: had to install anything other than
Caption: Docker and vs code
Caption: um and then if I when I'm finished
Caption: working on this delete the repo off my
Caption: machine and I don't have to uninstall
Caption: you know the cosmos emulator I don't
Caption: have to install the.net framework or
Caption: anything like that it's all isolated uh
Caption: and what this means is that yeah like
Caption: it's very easy to come across as like an
Caption: open source contributor pick up a
Caption: project clone it open it and have all
Caption: this uh like all the environment ready
Caption: to go you haven't had to read like a a
Caption: massive contributing guide or anything
Caption: like that
Caption: um the the next kind of power of this is
Caption: that if you're working with GitHub code
Caption: spaces uh when you open it in code
Caption: spaces it will detect the dev container
Caption: and provision the code space through
Caption: those specifications for you
Caption: um uh the the GitHub folks um over at
Caption: the the booth actually have this running
Caption: uh with another project of mine where it
Caption: is running a cosmos DBA emulator and a a
Caption: Docker container side-by-side inside of
Caption: code spaces and they're running that
Caption: from a Raspberry Pi so you're like doing
Caption: full development with two running Docker
Caption: containers off a Raspberry Pi
Caption: um but a Dev containers are really
Caption: useful for doing
Caption: um so yeah like this remote uh so this
Caption: pre-provisioned environment and it can
Caption: save so much time you know having to
Caption: install this uh keep these docs up to
Caption: date this is the right version of
Caption: whatever the dependency is that we need
Caption: to install you have it all there um uh
Caption: pre-built and combined into this one
Caption: folder
Caption: um all right we've got about
Caption: um I'm going to leave some time for
Caption: questions at the end um so uh we'll go
Caption: for about probably I think well like 10
Caption: minutes left I think uh I'm getting some
Caption: vagueness on that I'm also the thing
Caption: that's standing between everyone and
Caption: lunch so uh
Caption: um
Caption: uh I talked a bit about code spaces but
Caption: there is
Caption: one other thing that I will show off
Caption: because I think it is super cool
Caption: particularly in um and the fact that a
Caption: lot more of us are working from home now
Caption: I've got to find the right vs code
Caption: instance that I have open
Caption: where is it here here and I have so many
Caption: vs codes where are all the vs codes it's
Caption: not that one
Caption: is it this one no no I don't have it on
Caption: any of them
Caption: um there's an extension that I'm going
Caption: to install called live share
Caption: um and this should actually install
Caption: pretty quickly because I already have it
Caption: done live share there we go okay so live
Caption: share is a extension that uh it's a
Caption: this is I guess you'd call it a product
Caption: um we created Microsoft for uh doing
Caption: um
Caption: uh remote
Caption: pair programming I guess probably a good
Caption: way to do it a good way to describe it
Caption: so with live share I'm going to hit
Caption: share now that I've installed that
Caption: and what it's going to do is it's going
Caption: to start up a collaboration session from
Caption: my machine and uh it's gonna this is
Caption: probably going to not go as fast as I
Caption: would like it to go and that's going to
Caption: be very depressing but by by doing this
Caption: I can I'll then end up with a URL that I
Caption: can give out to you know someone that I
Caption: might be pair programming with and they
Caption: can connect from their machine uh to
Caption: essentially my vs code instance but they
Caption: don't actually have to have vs code
Caption: installed they can do it directly from
Caption: the browser they could open it up in
Caption: full visual studio and live share
Caption: actually works with um Visual Studio as
Caption: well as vs code
Caption: that's it share again ah there we go oh
Caption: cool we're gonna do a signing dance
Caption: everyone's gonna learn my password to
Caption: GitHub that
Caption: nope I should be already authenticated
Caption: uh so it's done okay
Caption: um it's collaboration session come on
Caption: there we go okay so that is open uh we
Caption: don't need Dutch I want to grab the URL
Caption: when it starts
Caption: here we go okay
Caption: session details
Caption: copy link okay excellent now
Caption: I'm going to paste this into the browser
Caption: and
Caption: it's going to start
Caption: vs code in the browser
Caption: so here we go
Caption: and it's going to take a few minutes or
Caption: hopefully not a few minutes it's going
Caption: to take a little bit of time because it
Caption: what it's doing is it's talking into my
Caption: laptop which is actually going uh I'm
Caption: going to continue on the web which is
Caption: going over the 5G connection on my phone
Caption: continue is anonymous
Caption: yeah we'll call that guest user uh and
Caption: they are going to be able to uh see like
Caption: all the files on my machine they're also
Caption: going to be able to connect to the
Caption: locally running web server that I've got
Caption: so they can view the the website well
Caption: which happens to be my blog um there we
Caption: go so there's all the files uh starting
Caption: to come in
Caption: uh I can open up let's just pick a
Caption: random file let's pick this package Json
Caption: um it's going to have syntax
Caption: highlighting and colorization and all
Caption: that kind of stuff in there but then as
Caption: the as the host of this collaboration
Caption: session I can see here's guest user7
Caption: there on that file and that line I can
Caption: go follow participant
Caption: let's just close off some of these okay
Caption: that's it oh sorry Focus participant no
Caption: follow to the side
Caption: and there we go I can see that's where
Caption: guest user is that there's a little
Caption: purple
Caption: um
Caption: carrot here which is uh where they are
Caption: put these Side by side-ish
Caption: and uh where let's go come on let's need
Caption: more space on my screen so so we're so
Caption: zoomed in uh okay and you can see as
Caption: that guest user clicks around we can see
Caption: what they're doing uh and then if I was
Caption: to come into let's go into here we want
Caption: to come into my graphql file
Caption: here we go so I can like remotely that
Caption: person like I can see in real time
Caption: what's happening
Caption: um you know if I'm making changes in one
Caption: uh uh in one editor those will be
Caption: reflected so if we yeah yeah if I was to
Caption: do that like that those changes would be
Caption: reflected across I said they get full
Caption: debugging um they can set break points
Caption: and all that sort of stuff um which is
Caption: really useful if you're doing like yeah
Caption: remote stuff
Caption: um a pair now pair programming pool
Caption: request reviews you know you just jump
Caption: on a call using whatever conference
Caption: calling platform you of choice and just
Caption: be like hey can we walk through this
Caption: together here's a live share link
Caption: actually live chat has built-in audio
Caption: support as well so you don't even need a
Caption: separate conference calling platform but
Caption: yeah it's like let's just walk through
Caption: this code together show me how that fix
Caption: is applied and all that kind of fun
Caption: stuff
Caption: and the very last thing about vs code
Caption: that I want to tell you is that they
Caption: have a tick tock account I don't know
Caption: what that is because I am too old for
Caption: Tick Tock but there it is
Caption: uh yeah yep
Caption: um tick tock.com
Caption: vs code uh yeah for for the younger
Caption: people in the room you might enjoy that
Caption: I said I'm just too old for tick tock uh
Caption: but it's there I've watched a bunch of
Caption: the videos like they're pretty funny
Caption: um but there's also a bunch of like
Caption: really uh useful informative things in
Caption: there like
Caption: um did you know I I learned from
Caption: watching one of their tick tocks that
Caption: you can change the scroll back history
Caption: in the terminal um by default it's like
Caption: a thousand lines but if you're doing
Caption: something that you know might be
Caption: outputting more than that
Caption: um you can change the scroll back depth
Caption: uh and you can you know and I learned
Caption: that from tick tock
Caption: yeah I'm like so hip and cool and Young
Caption: and look there's a thousand one other
Caption: things that you can do with vs code but
Caption: I'm just about out of time
Caption: I want to gain thank you our sponsors
Caption: for making sure that DVD Perth could
Caption: happen again this year um I'm I'm glad
Caption: to be back uh at a daily event I'm glad
Caption: to be back at the input person
Caption: conferences even though I'd forgotten
Caption: just how exhausting they are I'm pretty
Caption: sure my voice will give out before the
Caption: end of the day but
Caption: we've got a couple minutes for questions
Caption: um or you can run off and grab lunch
Caption: early at the very least thanks for
Caption: coming to my session today I hope you've
Caption: learned a couple of tips and tricks for
Caption: working with vs code and do feel free to
Caption: reach out after the session as well if
Caption: you want yeah thank you
Caption: thank you